what's up buzzfeed i'm ross lynch and
today we are here to read some thirst
tweets here we go how naughty are we
gonna get here
the first one says i so badly want to
boop and kiss ross lynch's nose that was
not that bad i could understand that
like i guess i got a cute nose that's
pretty uh pretty innocent ross lynch if
you see this i'm free thursday night are
you free thursday night so i can take
you out on thursday night if you're free
i'd like to hang out thursday night
please message me back if you're free
thursday night when i'm free
i don't think i was free thursday night
thursday i mean if that was yesterday we
were playing san francisco which was
actually a really really great show we
have this song called san francisco that
we played in san francisco the crowd
went wild it was good hot girls knew the
choreography for cruising for a bruising
from team beach movie because they had a
crush on ross lynch it was me i'm hot
girls
that was so fun doing cruising for a
bruising the only thing that sucked
about it though is i um like the night
before we were night swimming and i went
to do like a big swan dive in the pool
and ended up stepping on a pool filter
and it took a few of my toenails with it
so next time you watch that performance
just know that i was hurting
i was hurting but it was so fun man ross
lynch wearing a cowboy hat rosslyn's
wearing a cowboy hat rosslyn trying to
cowboy hat ross lynch wearing a cowboy
hat ross and scoring cowboy i don't know
where that started i think it was it was
probably harry styles i've like seen
pictures of harry styles wearing cowboy
hats on stage too but i swear every
single night five or six cowboy hats
thrown at me
it's kind of fun you get like outfit
changes mid mid set it's kind of cool
i'm kind of collecting them i guess now
there's too many so i usually pick like
my favorites ross lynch makes me go
feral every time i see a picture of him
like why does he have this power over me
i don't know i'm just trying to have a
good time
just up there dancing
singing enjoying myself
i guess that's the that's the secret i
remember ross lynch in team beach movies
specifically being my biggest sexual
awakening it's all his fault
that movie's like really innocent too
you know what's funny actually i didn't
think they let me take my shirt off for
that film they had me in this like
yellow rash guard the whole time and
they also for some reason they didn't
want maya and i to kiss in the first
movie
we kissed anyway
harry styles this harry styles that
y'all be sleeping on ross lynch and
missing out sorry not sorry but this man
right here
sexy a legend chef's kiss an absolute
[ __ ]
love him it's weird that [ __ ] like a
compliment now how did that happen i
guess harry styles is like the dude
right now i guess it's always in
comparison with harry styles but it
doesn't really need to be we can both
thrive and have a good time i think
harry's dope ross lynch could literally
snap me in half and use me like a glow
stick on a bonfire night i think half of
these tweets are from boys ross lynch is
daddy af and i don't hear enough well
i'm hearing it a lot today
i want ross lynch to redacted
redacted redacted me so hard that i
redacted redacted redacted what does
redacted mean again it's like beep
that's funny religion ross lynch's
thighs really my thighs how do you see
my thighs sweet i'm a hockey player so
like i have thicker legs i guess when i
lick ross lynch's happy trail till i get
rug burn on my
tongue dang i think it's funny too
because this is when i lick but i don't
know this person and people are creative
on twitter they really are ross lynch is
for the gays no babe
he's for all the [ __ ] out there
actually
i'm gonna i'm in a relationship
currently my next song coming out our
next song as the driver era it's called
fantasy you can listen to that and
fantasize all you want
ross lynch could suffocate me and i'd
resurrect just to say thank you
man that was pretty good that was pretty
good i don't care if i'm a lesbian i
would let rosslyn trail me wow that's a
pretty cool compliment thank you i also
like girls so that's cool
i want ross lynch to choke me with his
thighs that person's definitely a
wrestler i would literally let ross
lynch
blow my whole back out any day of the
week
any hour of the day
damn
i would eat ross lynch's ass
i would do anything that man asked of me
well i probably wouldn't
ask
you to do that just sadly living another
day knowing ross lynch still has not
murdered this
bussy with a b but i think we all know
what she means
that's pretty funny we're really getting
into some thirst tweets for sure okay
you know what i'm gonna say it i'm a
hole for ross lynch damn
people it's so funny to me that people
tweet this i woke up from my nap to tell
everyone that i would suck ross lynch
off okay good night see like there's no
way her mom follows her there's no way
maybe that's like an account that she
just like is anonymous behind like not
even her friends follow or something
that's interesting it's very interesting
well guys that was thirst tweets about
me
ross lynch with buzzfeed
i hope you liked it i think it's really
interesting that people feel comfortable
to announce
those desires i hope you enjoy the art
that i create we're on tour right now we
got a record coming out on september
16th band's called the driver era the
summer mix tape the focus track is
called fantasy so if you're feeling
this kind of way you can listen to that
song and fantasize all you want thanks
for watching make sure you subscribe and
comment and like and everything like
that and uh
i'll see you next time buzzfeed
[Music]
uh